spacecraft tens of billions of miles
away rely on this network of satellite
dishes to communicate with Earth but
this system is in trouble the deep space
network is operating at capacity and
can't keep up with increasing demand
which experts say could lead to loss of
important scientific data like
information about the sun's magnetic
field if nothing is done the thought of
not having that constant connection to
our astronauts to his key science
missions it's a challenging and a
concerning uh topic here's how NASA's
infrastructure got to this critical
stage and what it'll take to fix it the
deep space Network or DSN uses radio
frequencies to send and receive data
like this image of the Southern Ring
Nebula from the James web telescope or
the sounds of dense plasma captured by
the Voyager spacecraft as it studies
Interstellar space the DSN also commands
tracks and monitors the health and
safety of spacecraft like Juno which is
studying Jupiter what we do in space
transfers directly to the Earth think
about the Imp that Apollo had on what we
do today camera systems the technology
transfer into the industry there were
certain fields that didn't even exist
before Apollo like software engineering
because a spacecraft's radio signals are
being transmitted from billions of miles
away they're incredibly faint by the
time they reach Earth that's why the DSN
uses these giant parabolic dish antennas
and Ultra sensitive receivers there's a
total of 14 antennas at three complexes
around the world so spacecraft can reach
the network no matter where they are
each complex has 170 m which is really
really large it's like most of a
football field and then a series of 34 M
antennas when data leaves a spacecraft
it travels back to an antenna where it's
decoded by the local facility then sent
here to the space flight operations
facility in Pasadena
California where it's routed to the
appropriate Mission Control
Center but strain on the DSN has been
growing for years according to a July
Inspector General report demand is
exceeding Supply by as much as 40% at
times and studies show that number will
reach about 50% by the 2030s because of
this the DSN has been forced to
prioritize some missions over others
which has led to delays in data for some
lower priority missions this happened
during Artemis 1 in 2022 LIF off of emus
one though it was an uncrewed mission
NASA prioritized its access to the
network because it's preparing the
agency to send humans to the moon for
the first time in over 50 years we
tracked aremis 1 like we will track it
when it has on board we definitely do
not want to lose communication with
astronauts right as a result all other
missions that use the network lost over
1,500 hours of data collection time
during that period for example the James
web telescope lost about 185 hours of
data transmission time when it normally
would have been able to immediately send
images back to Earth even though James
web and the other missions were able to
eventually make up for that lost time
Smith says these delays could turn into
losses in important data if nothing is
done to increase capacity on the network
Baldwin says he's especially concerned
given the ambitious goals the agency has
for emis the human Landing the Gateway
system the commercial Landers it's going
to be challenging to meet all the
objectives of all the things we want to
do include science and the human
exploration portion of it the DSN will
face an even greater strain when the
Network's largest capacity users will be
in the same part of the sky vying for
the same antennas it's very possible
James web will take a hit on their
science data collection Europa C as we
build up the AR 3 and Beyond the psyche
mission that just launched really it's
users that require a lot of DSM time
that takes the most amount of impacts so
why is the DSN in this dire State one
reason is that a lot of missions are
lasting much longer than originally
anticipated Voyager which launched in
1977 is still transmitting data from
Beyond the solar system it is still
going strong 46 years later our mission
load just keeps growing because we've
got all the new missions and then we
also have older missions that continue
to operate but the big reason is that
the dsn's infrastructure some of which
was built in the 60s has become
increasingly difficult and costly to
maintain and that cost does increase we
have inflation supply chain issues that
impact us and so there's a list of
things that will impact our ability to
move out on these antenna builds and
also to maintain our operational and uh
Readiness to support these missions some
major upgrades also take antennas
offline for months at a time which can
increase pressure on the already
overburdened nwor we've had issues of
complexes going down that happened on
arnus we had a complex go down that we
had to bring back up we've had uh axles
break in our antennas the agency has
also had difficulty building new
infrastructure its 2010 initiative to
build six new antennas is nearly five
years behind schedule when we're talk
about long-term it's challenging there
will need to be investment to sure that
we can support the long-term plans of
NASA one potential fix a network of
smaller antennas to specifically serve
lunar missions so it can offload those
missions from the DSN the first of these
antennas is set to be built by 2026 NASA
is also testing the use of optical
communication or lasers on the
spacecraft studying the psyche asteroid
psyche has a tech demo on it right now
so instead of sending radio frequency
signals through an antenna it will use a
laser to encode data Baldwin says the
DSN is also leaning on other space
agencies around the world borrowing
their antenna networks when needed they
did help us with arm one when we had to
shift some of the missions over to uh
other International agencies we did that
we are going to explore that for arus 2
and Beyond as well despite these efforts
Baldwin says the DSN isn't out of the
woods yet we're concerned right it's uh
maintaining schedule is key and
difficult with some uncertainty in
budget so I'd be remiss to saying that
there's no worry that we're all good
we're the first time in 50 years the DSN
is going to be supporting human space
flight but we're also supporting all of
these other missions so it's a load on
the DSN than what we've had recently for
the public to know that we are being
good uh stewards of taxpayer dollars and
ensuring that we can bring down that
investment that they made into the
science expiration I think it's
[Music]
key